- Um...
this team is the second-best team in California.
♪♪♪
- [Taylor Rooks:] All right, Dwyane Wade, welcome into Just Playin'.
One thing I have learned about athletes is you all
want to win, whether it's in your actual sport or if it's
game night or whatever the case may be, you're gonna do
what you can to get that W.
We're gonna play Heads Up.
Which I'm gonna show something on my phone, you get me to guess the word.
Our first category, we're gonna do basketball.
- This a softball category, ain't it?
- Yes, exactly. But the next one will be a little harder.
But we'll warm you up with some basketball.
Yeah, this ain't gonna go good.
Ready, set, and I'll close my eyes so I cannot see.
♪♪♪
- Uh, when the ball goes to the sideline,
and the ref blows the whistle..
- Inbounds?
- Not inbounds.
- Out of bounds?
- There you go, yup.
- He's Mister Triple-Double.
- Russell Westbrook.
- Yup.
- This team right here...um...
is in the city that I live, uh,
I live in California. This team is the second-best team in California.
- The Los Angeles Clippers.
- Yes, there you go.
- [Laughing]
- He's one of the greatest college coaches ever.
- John Wooden.
- No, OK. Not—
- Coach K.
- There you go, yup.
-Uh, this is something that I, my last year in the NBA, I came
off of the...um...
With the Miami Heat, I came off the what?
- Off the bench.
- I didn't start.
Yeah, c'mon!
- [Laughing]
- Ahhh, so, end of the second quarter is what?
- Halftime! Halftime?
- Yep.
- Yes!
[Laughing]
OK, give yourself some credit.
Those were good clues.
We got one, two, three, four, five, six.
We got six. Look at that.
And you have switched seats in so many ways, where like you went
from player to kinda media hosting role.
What is one perspective that you had on the media when you
were playing that is not a perspective that you
have on the media now?
- Well, that they was haters.
- [Laughing]
Yeah.
- Simple as that, right? You look at guys who, first of all,
we're in studio, right? If I'm lookin' at TNT, and I talked
about this on the interview recently with Charles Barkley,
who I love.
But, you know, if he's in the studio, I'd never see him at
the arenas. I'd never see him at practice.
And he's away from the game for 10, 15, 20 years.
And the game is different.
And if he's talkin' about, you know, the players today, or he's talkin'
about the game today, or he's talkin' about certain things
you're doing, and it's comin' out, and you hear it.
If you one of those teams that's on TV every week, you
hearin' it every week. And so you like, "Yo, why he keep
coming at me?"
- Yeah.
- And so, I think you think they're haters.
But then once you get on their side, you understand that
everything is just opinion-based, something is motivational-based.
I think Shaq gets a rap because he comes at guys,
and, you know, guys should come back.
But a lot of 'em for Shaq, in his mind, this is for me to
motivate you.
- Mmhmm.
- So you start gettin' into the minds
of people that's at the desk and what they have to do
to, you know, to talk about the game, to build ratings,
to stay up long nights, you know,
- Yeah.
- it's one, two in the
morning, you know, all these things.
- If you had to play in a game right now, could you still,
could you still make sumthin shake?
- Right now?
- Right now, this exact moment.
- Nothing, nothing.
- Nothing?
[Laughing]
Nothing, you're out!
- Nothing. Actually, someone just asked me that. Someone, actually, cuz
they was like, "Yo, if you can, can you get ready for the playoffs if the
team needs you?" I said absolutely not.
- [Laughing]
- No! Like, don't discredit what it takes to be a
professional athlete.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean? And to be good
- Mmhmm.
- and to be productive.
My body will break all the way down.
- [Rooks laughing]
- C'mon, give me an easy one to start off, y'all.
Don't be playin'. OK, one of the biggest shows
ever. It was two women.
- Not "I Love Lucy"?
- No, not "I Love"—
- "Golden Girls"?
- Whew, ahh.
- It goes from cars to something that
goes to, like, um...
- Transformers?
- I think this is a doctor show?
- "ER"? "House"?
- In California...
- "Grey's Anatomy"?
- In California.
- "General Hospital"?
- The O.C.?
Is that...is that Cali? I don't know.
[Both laughing]
- It's Cali, but it's not about doctors.
- People add all the things that they do to, like, their
Instagram bio.
Yours could say, OK, NBA on TNT Tuesday, part
of the Utah Jazz ownership group, Wade Cellars.
Now you have this huge new project hosting "The Cube" on
TBS, which premieres on June 10th.
So tell me, what exactly is
"The Cube"?
Well, "The Cube" is exactly what it sounds like. It's a cube.
You know, in this game, we have roughly, what,
about 62 different variations of games that you can play.
And you don't know which ones will come up.
But what makes the game cool for me is
you get nine lives
to win $250,000, you know? So that's a lot of bread.
- And correct me if I'm wrong, but if there's something that
they can't do, they are allowed to pull
you in for one shot.
- Yeah, yeah. So we gave the contestants two assists
as well. So they get nine lives,
but they also can call on The Cube to kinda simplify one of
the games if they get in a tough situation.
And also they can call on me to come in and and play one
game, but it has to be a one-player game.
And I can come in, and I get one chance to try to win this
money for them.
- If you were in The Cube, and you could call
on one current NBA player who has
to make one shot for you, who do you call?
- Steph Curry.
- Curry, easy.
[Both laughing]
Our producers made a custom pack called Wade's World.
They did a deep dive on your Instagram.
Got a bunch of little tidbits about you.
So this pack, your Wade's World pack, is all about you.
So you gotta get 'em right.
- I got this one.
- Oh this is the water mobile
that you, LeBron, your wife and....
- Banana boat.
- Yes.
Oh, oh, my gosh! The best poultry in Chicago.
Mild sauce.
- Uhh, Harold's Chicken.
- Yep.
- Uhhh, OK. I don't know what this is, but OK. Blank
Rivers, the basketball player right now.
Blank Rivers.
- Austin Rivers?
- OK. And then and...?
Austin and....uh...
- "Austin & Ally"?
- Yes. Yes.
[Laughing]
OK, this is an old show, like,
a whole bunch of, like, people in a bar.
- "Cheers."
- Yes.
- Oh! Rapper.
Ice. Oh, your show!
The...
- Cube! Ice Cube.
- Yeah, no, no, yeah.
It's cube. Yeah.
[Laughing]
Oh, this is a wine, a red wine.
- D Wade Cellars.
- No, no, no, no, no. A specific wine.
- Uhh...
- What's another word for taxi?
- Cab? Cab, yeah, cabernet.
- Yeah. Woooo! Yay! Hey, we did pretty good.
Wait, what is "Austin & Ally"?
It was a show that was on. It's like a kid's show, and I was on it.
- Oh! OK. I'm like, oh, my God, I do not know how to get him
to say Ally! But...no, that was good.
You gotta give me, like, a...
Ready?
There we go. Good job.
We are going to move on to the Rapid Fire segment.
Fill in the blank.
Dwyane Wade is __?
- Nice.
[Both laughing]
- First pair of sneakers
- Ellesse?
- Oh, yeah? Last meal.
- Burger.
- Childhood crush.
- Gabrielle Union.
- Awwww! All right, biggest fear.
- Oof. Me and birds, we really...I'm tryin' to get
better, but the birds and I just, we really don't vibe too much...
- OK, birds.
I'll remember that...
Biggest L?
Biggest L? Umm.
Life is, and I say L as in I don't take it as a loss. I take it
as lessons.
So the L in lesson. So life is a lesson, and that's the
biggest L you can get.
- I like that. OK, advice to your rookie self.
- Advice to my rookie self...
Try to be, try to be able to look in the future
and understand that the game is going to go to
three-pointers, and so start shooting 'em very early so you can
have a long career.
[Both laughing]
- Hey, and that's life advice.
Everybody look to the future.
- Yup.
- Work on your three-point shot. Whatever that shot may be,
work on it.
- Yep.
- Well, that was amazing. Thank you so much for joining, D.
And everybody, make sure you watch "The Cube" on June 10th
on TBS.
- Thank you! That was fun.